[Musica]
[Applauso]
ciao ragazzi benvenuti al mio primo blog
interattivo in questa giornata ho deciso
di chiedere a instagram di pilotare la
mia giornata cosa sarà il mio ultimo
giorno di mare a filicudi sono curioso
di vedere che cosa succederà ci tengo a
dire che questa non è una mia idea ma
sono stati la vigna e gianmarco obbliga
a fare questa cosa se ci fosse stato
enrico a cosa sarebbe successo niente di
diverso forse peggio che a questo punto
di armarmi del mio profilo di instagram
e partire subito facendo dei video nei
quali darò dei dvd azioni che potrò fare
e che misero avrà trenta minuti per
potermi dire che cosa scegliere fra le
due cose che proporrò partiamo allora
primo bivio devo andare al mare ci vado
scalzo in un sentiero di ciottoli
rischiando l'ustione alle piante di
piedi oppure bendato rischiando di
impedimento e morire e uccidermi da solo
ha vinto ben dato è presente questo
cretino un po particolare però non
credibilità richiedi 3 eccolo finiscono
qui perché è un'ottima tecnica dove
giocano di moria che la sporgenza ma
cosa succede qui c'è un proseguimento
siamo pronti colonnello punti pronti
stai molto attento perché è strapieno di
cactus segui il viale segue piani
ragazzi cosa se vuol dire che non vedo
niente sostanzialmente che ce n'è uno
che vai avanti
ok è liberato bravo hai del potenziale
stanno sudando gli occhi e non è pianto
accelera c'è da dire verso sinistra vale
se ne piloti come di lonato androne
facciamo vedere nel frattempo che fine
ha fatto il drone le sue ultime riprese
[Musica]
vieni con top 30 piedi che bellissimo
quella basca
ma ci stanno gradini no no no no è tutto
un via così bravo complimenti ma perché
abbiamo fatto questa cosa si sta facendo
mi si sta bruciando la rete molti
diverte sì esatto
mamma mia ragazza una fatica
sei arrivato guarda che bel posto il
sole mi fa male agli occhi
allora ce l'abbiamo fatta sono morto
continuano i bivi in cui abbiamo da una
parte una sfida di nuoto sincronizzato
trame giammarco o una lotta io contro
gianmarco con ragazze sopra di noi come
ti vedo stabile è difficile guardare
potrebbero coi tacchi si deve vedere che
ne so se facciamo così
[Risate]
[Applauso]
[Musica]
giorni come ti senti rosso dire che sono
molto soddisfatto del fatto che io posso
dirti che anch'io pensavo molto molto
peggio
secondo me è 2024 le olimpiadi
potrebbero chiamare cinema che oggi si
faccia pierfrancesco oggi e.on sani
essere ripreso e mille riprenderemo
seguitelo su instagram puro
ho paura che questo video risulta
inutile la domanda è torna a casa con la
macchina oa piedi e insacca riuscirà
eccolo
ti prego dio la mano gregotti no
vibrando non ti muovere a compassione
[Musica]
[Applauso]
è una cattiveria è tutto così cattivo
vorrei farvi sentire una cosa il nostro
6 sentite che si abbatte anche a pato da
interni sono pratici o andata benissimo
invece di fare il filosofo è calata la
notte nel frattempo va bene dovevo fare
la prossima sfida giusta ma lasciamo
alla prossima sfida
guarda già alla prossima sfida chissà
cosa sceglieranno nei versi che siccome
cuore apparirà la stories verrai
trattata tipo come microsoft altro bivio
o vado a farmi una doccia calda oppure
li faranno la doccia i miei familiari
iniziamo a prendere il turbo diciamolo
sta impostando il sacro studio dell'anno
però lo stupido e tutte le presenze
molto belli e la tradizione è nata nel
chissà quanto ancora andrà oltre secondo
te ma almeno due mesi se non moriamo
prima dai fortuna devo riprendere perché
io a farti la doccia sinceramente non ci
avrei tenuto particolari posso dirti non
[ __ ] compiacenti alla finale di
champions i moli dove solo di questione
mamma mia che piacere a chi accede alla
finale di champions league ha mai
assegnato a un po si chiama parrucchiera
pazzesca cervello
anche questo noi vi facciamo uno shampoo
come una da lei come lui
vivete nei commenti che invidioso nei
confronti di vittoria una modifica ma
lobont da una vita non essermi mai fatto
una doccia così bene ringrazio la rai
come microsoft chi cucina la cena la
linea oppure io sono i ragazzi che mi
avete fatto di cuore
marco tipico quelle falangette amor di
maledetto
ciao ragazzi e ben tornati ad un
episodio di cucina buttata con l'ad
andiamo nella mia cucina mica come
quella di questo poveraccio dietro la
camera da quanto il cinema questo
comodissimo quella che ti faccio tifo
razzo anche un po meno di questa cucina
perfettamente attrezzata ma povera di
tipo pezzi di mattonella ai fornelli
della vendetta del web caduta o un piano
perché voglio cavalcare il fatto che il
web forse mista da nino mano avevo con
domanda che apparecchia risposta è
chiara chiesa che vedo che appare chiaro
che io conosco e mi puoi abbonare 2084
versanti 2000 comunque momento ci stanno
aspettate che vado a votare anche io ho
fregati come va ragazze molto bene ho la
mia su sardo che mi sta aiutando abbiamo
purtroppo come dice con la cucina povera
di materie prime non fatte sia enorme
quindi possiamo fare solo una pasta
soffritto di aglio pomodorini e ricotta
siciliana infornata amico ma vediamo con
quello più bello
improvvisamente il web che
effettivamente tu me lo puoi prevedere
stupisce e t tende e evidente la mano
perché il web aiuta sempre gli ultimi
ma che bella tavola è una congiura ma
qual è l'ingrediente segreto ingrediente
segreto del soffritto a cannes segreto
sono io ed e cornet e dinamiche no
guarda non lo scopo è pronto
a a beneficio di cronaca non l'ho scelta
io la pasta dentro questa casa ci sono
solo pennelli e cioè lo dico proprio per
perché voglio voglio farti di questo
mette responsabilizzo
ecco come la cottura mia cena caso la
lapi ragazzi a venire a cena data ora la
baguette preparati che l'ultimo video di
oggi arriviamo chi lo fa io il mio
cugino classe 87 con la coppetti nato il
7 n'erano l'anarchico meschino 35 per
cento non è stato 500 loro sapere perché
potevano coppiettina perché siamo
stanchi di vedere gente felice che sta
insieme skill innamorati fanno schifo
quando lavare i piatti pensa doveva
scattare questa classe 87 si fa sentire
comunque guglielmo la pagherà per questo
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video vi ringrazio per le
votazioni specialmente per le ultime che
mi hanno sollevato da qualsiasi tipo di
incarico da eseguire durante questa
serata questo qui è l'ultimo video e il
giovedì di questa vacanza dal prossimo
ritorneremo purtroppo a roma che altro
dire se vi è piaciuto questo video
mettete un pollice in su si vede al
canale lasciateci un commento facendoci
sapere come fine di questa vacanza o se
l'è inizierete noi ci vediamo presto un
bacio a domenica con cucina buttata ciao
lei non ha fatto niente lui ha guidato
ai bisonti muscoli sono contento di
andarmene nome dei capi gli ha fatto il
compito più ingrato e si è offerta che
nei ragazzi nera aveva un sorriso che
veramente sulle labbra stampa dono prego
i kit